this is Elon Musk one of the inventors
of PayPal he also is in charge of Tesla
Motors and now SpaceX and he's actually
embracing one of the rocket boosters for
one of his rockets he talked about the
physics of a company with me and a very
again very humble point of view he said
sometimes you can get a small group of
people a band of merry brothers and
sisters who are all united in a common
goal they believe in each other they
believe in their vision now this small
company can outdo a massive corporation
filled with thousands more people but
they're all competing against each other
they're all trying to trip each other up
to get the promotion